[MUSIC PLAYING]
ADAM GREEN: I would
love to bring out--
guys, put your hands
together, give a big Google
welcome for Ed Robertson,
Kevin Hearn, Jim Creeggan,
and Tyler Stewart from
the Barenaked Ladies.
[APPLAUSE]
ED ROBERTSON: Oh, keep it
going for Adam, everybody!
That's Adam!
TYLER STEWART: You need to refer
to us as your highnesses now
'cause we're royalty, right?
ED ROBERTSON: I got to admit, I
met Adam only a short time ago.
I didn't realize what
you were capable of.
That was incredible.
[LAUGHTER]
Adam, everybody.
Google that guy.
He's going places.
[APPLAUSE]
The guy's amazing.
KEVIN HEARN: He'll
be back up later.
ED ROBERTSON: Yeah, can't wait.
[MUSIC - BARENAKED LADIES,
"CANADA DRY"]
[APPLAUSE]
ED ROBERTSON: Thank you.
That's a song we
wrote with Adam.
[LAUGHTER]
KEVIN HEARN: That's from my new
record called, "Fake Nudes."
ED ROBERTSON: Just how
wired up is this room?
Is it-- it's all right?
I just want to try something.
OK, Google.
Activate emergency services.
[LAUGHTER]
Nothing?
KEVIN HEARN: Not that
wired up apparently.
ED ROBERTSON: You guys got
to implement that shit.
[LAUGHTER]
KEVIN HEARN: OK, Google.
Tune Ed's guitar.
[LAUGHTER]
ED ROBERTSON: This is another
one from "Fake Nudes."
It's called "Bringing It Home."
[MUSIC - BARENAKED LADIES,
"BRINGING IT HOME"]
[APPLAUSE]
ED ROBERTSON: Thank you.
Speaking of royalty,
Royal Wood's back there.
Hi, Royal.
How are you?
Royal won a contest
to be here today.
[LAUGHTER]
They said "Royal, who
are your biggest heroes?
And who would you like to
see in an office building?"
[LAUGHTER]
They said, "Royal, who's
nominated for this year's
Hall of Fame awards and
still plays in an office
building on Richmond Street?
[APPLAUSE]
KEVIN HEARN: Let this be an
inspiration to you, Royal.
ED ROBERTSON: It never stops.
[LAUGHTER]
This is what you're
currently striving for.
Seems like just yesterday we
opened the Buns Master Bakery
in the Scarborough Town Center.
How far we've come.
TYLER STEWART: I'm just
going to correct that.
It was the Open Window Bakery.
ED ROBERTSON: Oh, you're right.
TYLER STEWART: You know?
Buns Master-- they
had to stop making
bread because of their name.
What-- with the
mainstreaming of porn.
I mean, there was
a lot of confusion.
People googled Buns Master--
ED ROBERTSON: The domain
name was already registered.
(SINGING) It's all in name--
a domain name, I mean.
We're Barenaked
Ladies, and we're
live on the scene at 111
Richmond, having a good time.
The people of Google
are here, and they're
all friends of mine.
This room is all wired up,
so you can say, "OK, Google."
It will tell you anything.
Even if you lose
your noodle, you
can get the things you want
like the lights turned down.
Or if you want some music,
"OK, Google, play some sounds."
That's all you have to
say to get this done.
We're Barenaked Ladies,
and we are the only one
who will be playing in this
building today and, later on,
be inducted to the hall of fame.
And then we'll be gone.
KEVIN HEARN: (SINGING) Buns,
Buns, Buns Master, Buns, Buns--
ED ROBERTSON:
(SINGING) OK, Google.
OK, Google.
[APPLAUSE]
OK, Google, upload that
to the Google Play Store.
[LAUGHTER]
This is a song that was on
our very first release, which
came out in 1908.
It was originally a
player piano reel.
TYLER STEWART: Funny thing
is Google's Headquarters
were here then, except
they were in a saloon.
ED ROBERTSON: That's right.
All right, here we go.
[MUSIC - BARENAKED LADIES,
"ENID"]
[APPLAUSE]
TYLER STEWART: Thank you.
ED ROBERTSON: Thank you.
TYLER STEWART: Look, we
were so good with that woman
had a baby!
[LAUGHTER]
ED ROBERTSON: Don't
wake the baby.
Security, have her removed.
TYLER STEWART: But
leave the baby with us.
ED ROBERTSON: I hate when people
hate when babies are around.
TYLER STEWART: You like it like
on airplanes or something--
ED ROBERTSON: It's like, "Ah!
Who would travel with a child?
I was going to sleep.
And then a human being came.
I hate when they're small!
I arrived at this earth
at age 50 and grumpy.
How dare that woman
feed her tiny human!
Isn't there a bathroom
you could do that--"
No, that's where people piss!
I'm not feeding my
child in the bathroom!
You didn't think it was going to
get political, did you Google?
[LAUGHTER]
TYLER STEWART: Holy smokes.
ED ROBERTSON: Whatever you
need to do with your baby
is OK with us.
We love that you're here.
We love that your baby is here.
And we hope your
baby will grow up
to never have any
recollection of this moment.
[LAUGHTER]
KEVIN HEARN: It's the
adults we don't like.
[LAUGHTER]
ED ROBERTSON: I'd much rather
be on a plane full of babies
than have one plane
with one guy who hates
that there's a baby on a plane.
[LAUGHTER]
TYLER STEWART: That's going
to be on our rider now.
Yeah, 26 or a Jack
Daniels and a baby.
[LAUGHTER]
ED ROBERTSON: This song was
written for babies, but--
JIM CREEGGAN: It's
a great combination.
ED ROBERTSON: Yeah.
KEVIN HEARN: It's called,
"Baby, It's Cold Outside."
[LAUGHTER]
JIM CREEGGAN: Oh
no, wait a second.
ED ROBERTSON: You start it.
TYLER STEWART:
That means I sing.
ED ROBERTSON: Yeah.
TYLER STEWART: I'm
counting myself in.
That's really
ridiculous, isn't it?
[LAUGHTER]
ED ROBERTSON: Well, Kev
has to know too though.
TYLER STEWART: Oh, yeah.
Kev sings too.
Yeah, I've forgotten everything
with all this baby talk.
I've reverted.
JIM CREEGGAN: Should
I start with you guys
or just let it run?
ED ROBERTSON: You start
whenever you want, Jim.
That worked great.
I think, to have you solo
just out there with a--
that was cool.
TYLER STEWART: One, two--
[MUSIC - BARENAKED LADIES, "ONE
WEEK"]
[APPLAUSE]
ED ROBERTSON: Thank you!
KEVIN HEARN: We'll
be back in a minute.
ADAM GREEN: How do
you guys find levity
in that current
situation and decide
we're going to
take this situation
and turn it into a fun album?
ED ROBERTSON: Well,
I think that humor
is a big part of the way we've
always dealt with everything.
You know, all of our records
have currents of seriousness
through them.
And I think this
record is no exception.
But it was very strange for us
to see the American president--
current president-- pick up on
the name of our record and then
do a little word play on it
and start using the term--
ADAM GREEN: That was
really big for you guys.
ED ROBERTSON: Fake news.
I mean, I thought that's
great publicity for us,
but it's weird the
way he's attacking--
ADAM GREEN: It was bittersweet.
KEVIN HEARN: It's easy
to sort of be paralyzed
by the doom and gloom and
constant barrage of things
going on.
But we decided we would like
to be a counter to that.
And we've been feeling
that at our shows,
especially in the USA.
People are coming to our
shows for a moment of just--
TYLER STEWART: Respite.
KEVIN HEARN: Yes.
ADAM GREEN: And so you
mentioned that there's
a vein of seriousness in there.
Is this like a "well
guys protest album,"
or is this collectively you
four like rolling your eyes
and just being like, all
right, we've got to have fun?
TYLER STEWART: Well, the
name, also, of the album,
besides the associated
political stuff, is--
it's actually true.
ADAM GREEN: You're fake nudes.
TYLER STEWART: We're fake nudes.
We're Barenaked Ladies.
ADAM GREEN: Most of the time.
TYLER STEWART: Yeah, well, I
mean, how many times did we
get asked when we were younger,
"You guys, there's no--
there's no ladies,
and you're not naked.
You're four guys."
ADAM GREEN: This is the
the worst strip club ever.
TYLER STEWART: Yeah, exactly.
So we're finally
calling our own bluff
and saying, "Yeah,
we tricked you."
ADAM GREEN: 30 years later--
that's a long set-up.
JIM CREEGGAN: And I think--
I don't know if--
the name just kind of
came up when we're 18.
But Sam the American Eagle
did mention "bare naked"
in one of his speeches.
So really it kind of
comes full circle.
TYLER STEWART: Sam the
American eagle, of course,
is a popular muppet
character from 1981.
[LAUGHTER]
ADAM GREEN: Half of our
employees are like 22.
So they have no idea
what the muppets are.
JIM CREEGGAN: All right.
ADAM GREEN: I do,
but they don't.
KEVIN HEARN: Adam, Ed suggested
the name of the record
early on into the
recording process.
And it was just
one of those times
where it happened
easily and made sense.
And, yeah, so usually we wait
till after the record is done
and then figure out
what it's called.
But this time we do.
ADAM GREEN: I love
the humorous streak.
And humor is, in general,
something you guys are really
well known for.
Do you think that,
without that, you could
have lasted as long as you did?
Like, if you're stage
persona was more serious,
could you have gone for 30 years
hanging out with each other?
JIM CREEGGAN: I
don't think we could
have gone 30 years without
making each other laugh.
I think that's kind of the
first thing that got us through.
TYLER STEWART: I'm
going on 29 years
though of not making these guys
laugh, so just so you know.
ADAM GREEN: But you keep
trying, and that's what matters.
TYLER STEWART: Keep
swinging for the fences.
KEVIN HEARN: The other side
of the coin, of course,
is, if there weren't good
songs and well-crafted music,
I think the laughter stuff would
have become quite tiresome.
TYLER STEWART: I think
the critics across Canada
and America would be quite
happy if we weren't humorous,
you know, because you get this,
Canadian joke band, Barenaked
Ladies.
We'll let anyone sing the anthem
about the NBA All-Star Game.
We're known for our humor, but
you also remember the songs.
We take it very seriously.
And darn it, we taste good.
KEVIN HEARN: Tyler acts funny
in public, but he's not funny.
ADAM GREEN: He's a
moody, serious person.
ED ROBERTSON: Well, and take
the anthem, for instance.
When we wrote that, nobody
thought that'd be a hit.
[LAUGHTER]
KEVIN HEARN: And They
sing it at every game.
ED ROBERTSON: Yeah.
So now they sing it--
ADAM GREEN: Only
the gold medals.
ED ROBERTSON: --at
every sporting event.
TYLER STEWART: And when we
changed the lyrics two weeks
ago, people were really happy.
ED ROBERTSON: They
were so angry.
TYLER STEWART: Oh.
ED ROBERTSON: I hate when
things are inclusive.
Stop it!
TYLER STEWART: And I'm going
home to talk to thy sons.
[LAUGHTER]
ADAM GREEN: I will write
a strongly worded letter
to someone about this--
TYLER STEWART: Thy sons.
ED ROBERTSON: It's
amazing how angry people
were that we sang
Canada's official anthem
at the All-Star game.
People were angry.
If you're watching right now and
you're angry, you're an idiot.
[LAUGHTER]
An idiot.
A stone, cold idiot.
JIM CREEGGAN: The response
being, "No, you're an idiot."
ADAM GREEN: And probably
those words exactly.
JIM CREEGGAN: Back and
forth and back and forth.
ADAM GREEN: So controversy is
something you guys are actually
like not at all strangers to.
Some of your big break
comes back to controversy
over your name in the original
show at Mel Lastman's square.
ED ROBERTSON: It was actually
at Nathan Phillips' Square--
just down the street from here.
We were booked to play the
New Year's Eve show, which
was a city-sponsored event.
And the name Robertson
was considered offensive
at the time.
ADAM GREEN: I'm offended.
ED ROBERTSON: And
so, I guess there
was a lot of
anti-Scottish sentiment
at that time in the early '90s.
ADAM GREEN: It's a dark period
in our nation's history.
ED ROBERTSON: You're not
really the son of Robert.
ADAM GREEN: Dad's name is Jim.
ED ROBERTSON: No, yeah.
So we were asked to drop out
of the gig, which we did.
And we just went
and did another gig.
And then we got really
lucky about a week later.
Nothing else happened
in the world,
and so somebody
reported this story.
It actually was a
week after New Year's.
And Jim Slotek, I
think, from The Sun.
JIM CREEGGAN: The Sun first.
ED ROBERTSON: And then from
that, other media outlets
picked it up.
And it ended up
on the front cover
of The Star, the national paper.
So we, as a little
band from Toronto,
went from selling
400 cassettes a week
to selling 14,000
cassettes a week.
Yes, cassettes.
[LAUGHTER]
TYLER STEWART: A cassette
is a small plastic device
that housed--
[LAUGHTER]
--cellulose tape.
JIM CREEGGAN: And it rewinds
when you put your pen
in one of the holes.
TYLER STEWART: Your pen.
When you put your pen in it.
ADAM GREEN: Very
important to note that.
Actually, that
brings up something
that I do want to talk
to you guys about.
You've been around since
the days of cassettes.
Then you saw music
media change drastically
from cassettes, where you
got your start, and then CDs.
You actually released
an album on USB stick.
How cool is that?
ED ROBERTSON: Not
[LAUGHTER]
TYLER STEWART: Not anymore.
ADAM GREEN: Yeah,
because it was last week.
But how does the
medium change the way
you guys think about
an album, or does it?
Do you write the
same whether it's
going to be streamed
or someone's
going to like buy a physical
medium and hold it in
and, you know, treasure it?
ED ROBERTSON: Yeah, we certainly
don't make music thinking
about how people are
going to get it, you know?
We write songs because we're
trying to communicate ideas,
we're trying to
express something.
But the landscape has
so radically changed
from a time when people used
to line up to buy vinyl or a CD
to a time when, a month before
we've released the record,
most people already
have it, because it
was leaked at some point.
And digitally it's gone
all over the place.
I love the one side of
that in that, as a music
fan and a consumer with
a voracious appetite
for new music, I'm always
checking stuff out,
streaming it, going to
the website of a band,
downloading stuff.
I love the convenience of it.
I love being able to have my
music library in my pocket
wherever I go.
That's awesome.
But it's made it
tough as artists,
because that thing we do no
longer has a perceived value,
even though we all have these
fantastic devices ostensibly
for media.
I mean, I know we use them
for a lot of communication,
but a lot of--
ADAM GREEN: Mostly looking
at cat pictures, I think.
ED ROBERTSON: But a
lot of what people do
is watch movies and
listen to music.
And there is way more
people listening to music
now than ever in history.
But it's a lot harder to
make a living as a musician.
We're lucky.
I say this on behalf
of younger acts.
We were at our height
when the record industry
was at its height.
So we sold a ton of records.
And we built a huge base.
So now every year, we
can go out and tour.
And we play for 100,000
people every summer
in a matter of a
couple of weeks.
So we're fine.
But it would be really tough to
try and start out as an artist
right now.
You would have to find all
kinds of alternate ways
to make it work.
So I envy the tools that
emerging artists have
at their fingertips, whether
that be a very amazing home
studio that's included
in your laptop.
TYLER STEWART: That guys got
a great studio right there.
ED ROBERTSON: Yeah, right there.
Everything you need to
make a high-quality record
is sitting on your lap.
KEVIN HEARN: He's making
it right now with his mind.
ED ROBERTSON: But, you
know, the flip side of that
is there's so much
noise that it's really
tough to cut through all that.
ADAM GREEN: Now you mentioned
that you came to your peak
when the industry
was at its peak.
But it wasn't always
friendly to you guys, right?
Like, you got rejected
by every label.
I don't want to like
drag up old wounds.
But you got a lot of nos, and
you hustled your own start
selling your own tapes off
the stage and to your friends.
KEVIN HEARN: We were
mentioning humor before.
And the humor actually
made it challenging
for us to get support
from radio stations,
especially in the USA,
because it was easy for them
to write us off as
a novelty group.
So we had to keep
going down there.
I guess we were down there
six, seven months a year
building the audience.
Every time we went back,
we'd go from a club, then
a bigger club, than the
next time the theater.
Eventually, the radio
stations came onboard.
ED ROBERTSON: We were
selling out arenas in America
before Stunt came out.
The band had done
so much like work.
It's like we built a following
one person at a time,
because we really didn't
have any kind of major media
support or even label support
until after Rock Spectac.
Then I think, at that
point, we had actually
played for everyone in the
record company at some point.
And they'd all gotten onboard.
And we became like the
darling of the label.
Everybody liked us, but we
hadn't really gotten anywhere.
So the company really
rallied behind us.
And then Stunt came out and
debuted at number two or three
in America, and
everything changed.
KEVIN HEARN: And now we're
rereleasing Stunt on vinyl--
TYLER STEWART: Hoping
for the same thing.
KEVIN HEARN: It's never--
[LAUGHTER]
It's never been on vinyl
before, because vinyl went away
for a while.
ADAM GREEN: So why
do you think it
is that the industry thought
for so long you can't
be funny and be a musician?
ED ROBERTSON: Well,
I think the Beatles--
ADAM GREEN: That's why?
ED ROBERTSON: --got them really
sick of having humor in music.
ADAM GREEN: These guys hold
a grudge for a long time.
TYLER STEWART: Well, they hated
the Beastie Boys and Beck.
I mean, they just
didn't like them.
ED ROBERTSON: I don't know why.
I think people were looking
for a reason to dismiss us.
And humor was the
reason they chose.
ADAM GREEN: Got you.
TYLER STEWART: It was either
the humor or the shorts
we wore for 10 years.
[LAUGHTER]
ADAM GREEN: It's a
pants-mandatory mandatory
industry.
TYLER STEWART: Yeah,
yeah, mandatory pants--
things start to look up.
ADAM GREEN: I understand.
ED ROBERTSON: And to be
fair, we were idiots.
We never once went into a radio
station or a television show
or anything we did.
We were always idiots, because
we were having a great time,
and we were just being silly.
And I don't think we
did ourselves any favors
of trying to go, "Oh, no,
but check out the record.
There's a lot of really serious
material on the record."
I don't blame people for
having written us off,
because we sort of
made them write us off.
ADAM GREEN: You were just like,
here's another microphone,
let's have fun?
ED ROBERTSON: Yeah.
TYLER STEWART: Be yourself
at all costs kind of.
We were those kind of guys.
And we weren't interested in
putting a facade on or being
the coolest guys
in the room or--
KEVIN HEARN: Even
though we were.
TYLER STEWART: Yeah.
Barely.
Still are.
ADAM GREEN: Did that inform
how you guys would, let's say,
give advice to a young artist
about building their career
in this--
it's a very different
industry, but you guys
struggled to build your
success and had this be
yourself at all costs attitude.
JIM CREEGGAN: Well,
I think playing live
was the biggest thing that
we still carry through.
And I think that's one thing
that a young artist should
always do is to just keep--
really be good to each
other if you're a band
and carry through
and rub each other.
ADAM GREEN: Here's where
the name came from.
JIM CREEGGAN: Yeah, and I
think, even more now than ever,
playing live and being
present to your friends
is more important.
And it's the thing that
lasts through as things
change technologically and--
TYLER STEWART: Something
you can control.
The only thing we ever
really control in our career
is what kind of
a show we put on.
I mean, you were in here in
this room when we played music.
And it sounded pretty
good, and you liked it.
That's what happens
everywhere we play.
So if you have that
up your sleeve,
it's a lot easier than
trying to sell an image
or an idea or even a record.
KEVIN HEARN: You did like it?
[APPLAUSE]
JIM CREEGGAN: OK, just checking.
I don't want to take
Tyler's word for it.
ED ROBERTSON: Here's
another secret about music
is, yes, it's difficult
to become a big success
in the music industry.
But it doesn't matter, because
it's really fun to make music.
And I would be
making music still
whether I was in this
successful rock band
or not, because we all
make music because it's
what we love to do.
It's our passion.
And you can follow that passion.
If you want to pursue
music, you can do that.
At some point, maybe you
have to reassess and--
ADAM GREEN: Maybe you
have to get a real job,
but you can do it on the side.
ED ROBERTSON: Maybe.
But when I talk to kids who
are trying to make a go of it
as a band, I never
say, well, it's tough,
so have something
to fall back on.
I would never say that.
I would say, it's
tough, go for it.
ADAM GREEN: Yeah, make a plan A.
ED ROBERTSON: Go for
it with everything,
because it's the most rewarding
thing you could ever do.
But set yourself a horizon
and reassess at some point.
TYLER STEWART:
You're a little more.
You're a little more
tongue in cheek than that.
Usually you say,
"Yeah, don't have
something to fall back on."
ED ROBERTSON: I do,
and I say, "Drop
out of school immediately,
because I did,
and I'm a millionaire."
[LAUGHTER]
ADAM GREEN: Life advice
from Ed Robertson.
ED ROBERTSON:
Especially if you're
mediocre on your
instrument like I am.
[LAUGHTER]
TYLER STEWART: This is like,
never see a hot dog is made.
This is behind the scenes.
This behind the music.
Don't give it all away, man.
ED ROBERTSON: I've seen
how hot dogs are made.
I've been in the factory.
Still love hot dogs.
[LAUGHTER]
ADAM GREEN: So this whole
idea of do what you love,
you'll never work another day.
If you had to
though, do you guys
think you could
work like a desk job
and come and be
like office schmuck?
TYLER STEWART: Fuck no.
[LAUGHTER]
ADAM GREEN: You're totally
unemployable at this point.
TYLER STEWART: Absolutely.
JIM CREEGGAN: I spent a
lot of time volunteering
at my local school.
And I found I had to learn
a new job every time.
Like, I had to learn how to
make 800 pancakes one morning,
400 sausages.
ED ROBERTSON: That's the
same job technically, Jim.
[LAUGHTER]
That's flipping.
JIM CREEGGAN:
Gardening, gardening--
I had to learn how to garden.
I don't know.
I feel like I will
do what I need to do.
I think that as a musician--
ADAM GREEN: So
Jim is employable.
JIM CREEGGAN: What's that?
ADAM GREEN: Jim is employable.
TYLER STEWART: He's the
only employable guy.
JIM CREEGGAN: I'm just
putting myself out there.
ED ROBERTSON: Jim
would've been fine.
ADAM GREEN: The rest of you--
he stuck around for your sake.
JIM CREEGGAN: You guys
want pancakes, gardening--
KEVIN HEARN: Jim,
why do you feel
you're the right
person for those jobs?
[LAUGHTER]
JIM CREEGGAN: I think--
ED ROBERTSON: What are your
strengths and weaknesses?
JIM CREEGGAN: I just
think, when you play music,
one thing that
happens is that you
get to work with other people.
And you have to
accomplish something.
answer to an audience.
And I think that's just good
training for anything really.
TYLER STEWART: It's
like accountancy.
ADAM GREEN: Like in
this moment where
I think we should
answer to the audience.
TYLER STEWART: Oh.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
First of all, my father-in-law
from Musselburgh, Scotland
says hello.
TYLER STEWART: From what town?
AUDIENCE: Musselburgh,
just out--
TYLER STEWART: Musselburgh!
Everyone's got muscles!
Right?
You've got strong people
over there in Musselburgh.
I'm from a fat town.
It's just to the
south of that place.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: You reacted exactly
how I hoped you would.
[LAUGHTER]
ED ROBERTSON: He's going to
wonder why you're speaking
to him with a Pakistani accent.
[LAUGHTER]
Didn't she tell them
I was from Scotland?
[LAUGHTER]
TYLER STEWART: They can'nae
speak in [INAUDIBLE]..
ADAM GREEN: The Scottish
leg of your next tour
has being canceled.
TYLER STEWART: And
you were saying?
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
so, hello to Ian.
The other question--
so we put out
a Dory, which is where
people can submit questions.
And we had a couple of questions
about music recommendations.
So we have a lot of
expats in this office.
Raise your hand if
you're not from Canada
or didn't grow up
with Barenaked Ladies.
So lots of folks who are
new to Canadian music.
So including Barenaked
Ladies, if you
could give a new Canadian
a must-know list of music,
what would that be?
ED ROBERTSON: Are we talking
current or of all time?
AUDIENCE: Everything.
TYLER STEWART: I'll go
Bruce Cockburn first.
It's not Bruce Cockburn.
And that's the first
thing you've got to know.
My wife-- she's from
the US-- she came up,
and she says, "How
come everybody
calls them Bruce Cockburn?
It's spelled Bruce Cockburn."
ED ROBERTSON: It's
a silent "ck."
JIM CREEGGAN: Anyways,
that's a little inside story
for new Canadians.
It's Cockburn.
He's one of our
favorite musicians.
ED ROBERTSON: Joni
Mitchell, I'd say.
KEVIN HEARN: I'd recommend
an album called "Coke Machine
Glow" by Gord Downie.
TYLER STEWART: Yes, for sure.
I would say the second Sloan
album, "Twice Removed,"
is a good record.
I would say Rush.
But if you're not
from Canada, you
know who Rush is really, right?
So we should be
going a little more--
KEVIN HEARN: Our Johnny Cash,
who would be Stompin' Tom
Connors--
TYLER STEWART: Yeah, definitely.
KEVIN HEARN: --that would
be a good Canadian choice.
ED ROBERTSON: Or
Gordon Lightfoot, man.
KEVIN HEARN: Gordon Lightfoot.
ED ROBERTSON: Listen to
some Gordon Lightfoot--
"Gord's Gold."
TYLER STEWART: Yeah.
KEVIN HEARN: Bob Dylan has often
said that Gordon Lightfoot is
his favorite songwriter.
TYLER STEWART: Sarah Harmer--
check her out.
She's amazing.
ED ROBERTSON: "Little
Fire," that record--
is what it's called?
TYLER STEWART: "Oh Little Fire."
ED ROBERTSON: "Old Little Fire."
TYLER STEWART: Sarah McLachlan.
There you go.
She's great too.
JIM CREEGGAN: She's great too.
TYLER STEWART: All the Sarahs.
[LAUGHTER]
Sarah, Stills, and Nash--
they're like this super trio.
ED ROBERTSON: For
modern Canadian music,
listen to Bahamas,
listen to Alan Doyle,
listen to Donovan Woods.
TYLER STEWART: City and Colour.
ED ROBERTSON: City
and Colour, for sure.
KEVIN HEARN: Skydiggers'
new record is nice.
JIM CREEGGAN: Yeah, Feist.
Leslie Feist.
KEVIN HEARN: Metric.
TYLER STEWART: Metric.
Yeah, check the
Broken Social Scene.
And finally, the Beatles.
[LAUGHTER]
ED ROBERTSON: They're
from Omemee, Ontario.
[LAUGHTER]
Or Liverpool, Nova Scotia.
KEVIN HEARN: Thanks
for the question.
ED ROBERTSON: That's
all we have time for.
Adam, thank you.
[LAUGHTER]
ADAM GREEN: Open
the Pandora's box
of musicians'
favorite musicians.
We could be here for eons.
TYLER STEWART: I'd
rather open a--
what's that small thing
called you talk to?
JIM CREEGGAN: A cookie?
[LAUGHTER]
TYLER STEWART: I'd rather
open a Google Home Box.
I'm just trying to be
brand friendly and shit.
[LAUGHTER]
Jesus.
Corporatism is my first
foot through the door.
ADAM GREEN: Excellent
corporate sponsors.
So you guys have done--
is it-- like 1,500 shows
over the years?
ED ROBERTSON: We've done
1,500 shows this year.
[LAUGHTER]
ADAM GREEN: 1,501 now.
I would assume, at this
point, you guys all
have like a PhD in hotel stays.
So I want to know each of
your Barenaked Ladies hotel
stay top tip for all
the business travelers.
ED ROBERTSON: OK, here, this
is honestly my top hotel tip.
It doesn't matter what
city you're going to
or the reason
you're going there.
Get out of the hotel.
Eating at a hotel restaurant,
no matter how spectacular,
is a failure.
[LAUGHTER]
When you get into a town,
google best restaurant--
this is what I do in every town
regardless of how many times
I've been there.
I google "top five farm
to table Minneapolis."
And then I look at the reviews,
because the reviews are always
manipulated.
So I look for those.
And I figure it out, and I text
all these guys and say, "Hey,
I've got a reservation
four tonight at this place.
This is what it's called.
Let me know if you
want to join me."
And then I also google
"best coffee roastery."
And so you have to
do that in every--
it doesn't matter
how tired you are.
It doesn't matter how well
you think you know the city.
It is a failure to stay
in your hotel room.
Even if you have a
ton of work to do,
google what is cool around you.
Get out and see it and
do it and then come back
to your hotel room.
Eating in the
hotel is a failure.
JIM CREEGGAN: That's what I do.
Speaking of Google Maps,
it changed the way I tour.
So what I'll do is
I'll look, and I'll
find this the
closest bike lane--
you know, on Google Maps,
you can find the bike lane--
and then I just go there.
And I get to walk
through the city.
And it changed the way I tour,
because usually I get stuck,
and I don't know where I'd be.
TYLER STEWART: Cyclists
everywhere hate Jim Creeggan.
ADAM GREEN: Dragging his
double bass down the bike lane.
[LAUGHTER]
TYLER STEWART: After you do
what Ed said and get out,
here's something you don't do.
Don't come back to
your hotel room,
strip naked, roll around,
and lick the bed spread.
Don't do that.
ED ROBERTSON: Huge
mistake we made early on.
[LAUGHTER]
We were always sick.
TYLER STEWART: Yeah,
we were sick a lot.
[LAUGHTER]
ADAM GREEN: Kevin?
KEVIN HEARN: I'm good.
[LAUGHTER]
ED ROBERTSON: So
much comedy gold,
he doesn't want to
wade into these waters.
It's shark infested.
KEVIN HEARN: I was going
to say, Ed texts us,
and then that's when
we go and rob his room.
[LAUGHTER]
ADAM GREEN: And do terrible
things to his bedspread
and then go to dinner.
It's amazing.
So you guys are being inducted
into the Canadian Music
Hall of Fame this year.
Huge milestone.
[APPLAUSE]
Are there any mixed
emotions about that,
like thinking that's
the kind of thing
that old guys get and like--
ED ROBERTSON: What
are you trying to say?
[LAUGHTER]
ADAM GREEN: You're old, Ed.
You're old.
No, are there any
mixed emotions about
like attaining those goals?
When you start out as like a
bunch of teenagers with a tape
that you put
together yourselves,
and then you're always
striving for something,
and then you get it.
At this point, is
there any worry
like, oh, man, this is a
big thing that usually comes
at the end of people's career?
And I know you guys are always
a very forward-thinking band.
ED ROBERTSON: Well, there wasn't
a lot of worry about that.
ADAM GREEN: Good luck with
that acceptance speech.
ED ROBERTSON: But now--
TYLER STEWART: Oh, yeah,
now that you mention it--
ED ROBERTSON: Now I'm really
fucked bummed out, Adam.
[LAUGHTER]
TYLER STEWART: Thanks for
bringing us down, man.
ED ROBERTSON: I felt
honored and excited.
And now I just feel like old.
[LAUGHTER]
KEVIN HEARN: Minus nine
on the vibe meter, Adam.
[LAUGHTER]
ED ROBERTSON: No, you know what?
It's so exciting.
And for us, it's
coming at a moment
where the band is
really feeling great.
We just did the most
extensive Canadian tour
we've done in almost 20 years.
We loved it.
We had a great time together.
And we were all feeling good
about, not just the new record,
but we were putting old
stuff into the set list
that we hadn't played
in a long, long time.
And we had a ton of fun with it.
We released two
records last year.
We did a record with
the acapella group,
The Persuasions, called
"Ladies and Gentlemen."
We loved that.
Then we put out "Fake Nudes."
And we just kind of felt like
everything was going great,
and the band was in
a really good place.
And then we got
this news that we're
going to be inducted
into the Hall of Fame.
So I don't know.
It just came at a
perfect time for the band
where we weren't resting on
the laurels of our career.
We have been pushing forward.
And after the
Junos this year, we
had already planned a UK tour.
And we have an extensive
American tour in June and July.
KEVIN HEARN: And now
we don't need to do it.
ED ROBERTSON: Cancel
those, Alison.
Thank you.
We're Hall of Famers now.
We don't need to tour.
[LAUGHTER]
ADAM GREEN: So is
it now freeing?
Are there other goals
that you want to take off?
Or now is it just like,
let's just go and have fun,
and our spot in the Hall
of Fame is literally there,
we don't really need to worry,
we can whatever the heck
we want?
ED ROBERTSON: Well, we still
want to make good music.
I mean, our goal always has
been to make good records
and do good shows.
And we've never wavered from--
that's kind of our compass.
We're trying to do the
best shows we can do.
We're trying to
write good songs.
make good records.
And we've been super lucky.
We've had some
really big singles.
We've won a bunch of awards
and now the Hall of Fame.
But all of that has come from
pursuing this compass needle
of just trying to be
good at what we do
and take our craft seriously.
And as I always say, as
much as we joke around,
we really take
performance seriously.
And we work hard on
the music so that we
can goof around on the stage.
ADAM GREEN: Excellent.
Are there any other
questions from the audience?
ED ROBERTSON: What
about the baby?
[LAUGHTER]
I'll just take--
I want to take one
question from the baby.
Everybody be quiet.
[LAUGHTER]
Just one question.
No, shh.
Hi, Mom.
Just one question.
(IN CHILD'S VOICE) Where'd
did you get those shoes, man?
[LAUGHTER]
Well, baby, I'm glad you asked.
Can I call you baby?
You are a baby.
You're such a baby.
Just keep sleeping, you baby.
KEVIN HEARN: You didn't
answer the question.
ED ROBERTSON: My son got
me these shoes actually.
My son, Arden, is a
total sneaker head.
TYLER STEWART: It's thy son.
ED ROBERTSON: All
thy sons got thee--
KEVIN HEARN: All of us
bought you those shoes.
ED ROBERTSON: Thy sneakers.
ADAM GREEN: Foot Locker,
I think, is the answer.
ED ROBERTSON: Baby Foot Locker.
[LAUGHTER]
ADAM GREEN: All right, guys.
I think we're pretty
much out of time.
TYLER STEWART: Any questions
for the room at all?
Anyone interested?
Any questions we
haven't answered?
ED ROBERTSON: We'll
answer anything.
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ED ROBERTSON: Next question.
[LAUGHTER]
ADAM GREEN: Favorite
group or person
you've shared the stage with
for people on the live stream.
ED ROBERTSON: That's probably
a pretty easy answer.
JIM CREEGGAN: Yeah.
Neil Young.
ED ROBERTSON: Neil Young.
TYLER STEWART: Neil Young.
Yeah, twice we've
got to do that.
It's been amazing.
Yeah, totally.
Here's a great story about
playing with Neil Young.
We did a benefit for The Blue
Dot Foundation, David Suzuki's
environmental organization.
And Neil was on the
show, and we all
knew we were going to
do the finale with him.
But we thought we
were just singing.
But then in the rehearsal,
in the soundcheck,
he turned to Jim and said,
"Where's your big bass?"
JIM CREEGGAN: I said,
"Right over here."
ED ROBERTSON: Jim
learned the song.
He was ready.
JIM CREEGGAN: I was ready.
If that moment happened,
I was going to be ready.
And he said it.
He called me out.
And there it was.
TYLER STEWART: And he said to
me, "Get on those tubs, man."
And remember how fast
Roadrunner could go?
That's how fast I
got on the drums.
And then we were playing the
song, the vibe was happening.
It wasn't feeling really
good, and then he stopped us.
And he said, "That's great.
Don't give it away.
We'll see you tonight."
And soundcheck was over.
So he wanted that energy.
ED ROBERTSON: We didn't even
play through the song one time.
TYLER STEWART: Not once.
So that's sort of legendary
Neil Young behavior.
And we got to experience it.
JIM CREEGGAN: Rock school.
ED ROBERTSON: And we did Neil's
Bridge School Benefit Concert
out in San Francisco one time.
And it's one of the
highlights of my life
is to be playing this show.
The kids from the
school are on the stage.
The audience at
Shoreline Amphitheater
is like 18,000 people.
But you're performing
for the kids.
And there's two
shows in the day.
The lineups are crazy, because
Neil Young organizes the bill.
And he calls, and
it's like, well, I
guess this year it's going to
be Bruce Springsteen, Sarah
McLachlan, REM,
Barenaked Ladies.
That's a bill for a show.
And everybody
plays acoustically.
And Neil says, "If there's
any instruments plugged in,
I'll come out there, and
I'll unplug them myself.
No amplifiers.
This is an acoustic show."
But for me, the glorious
part of that whole thing
was Neil standing on
the side of the stage
watching our show
and just beaming.
I learned to play the
guitar to play old man.
And all these songs off Harvest,
so my older brothers would
think I was cool.
And there I was, playing for
a crowd, playing for kids,
but playing for Neil standing
on the side of the stage.
We got to go to a
barbecue at his house.
Neil's house is,
first of all, amazing.
And we're walking around.
And just the knick-knacks
around his house
are like a rock-and-roll museum.
And Neil came in and
said, "Are you guys OK?
You got everything you need?"
And I said, "Neil, I
hope you don't mind.
We're pretty big fans.
So I've pocketed a few
things just as a reminder."
And he didn't even skip a beat.
He just said, "Do you want
a gym bag or something?"
[LAUGHTER]
He's amazing.
So the answer-- Neil Young.
TYLER STEWART:
Second place, close--
Dee Snider from Twisted
Sister at Massey Hall.
Two years ago, we did "We're
Not Going To Take It."
And it was the most
rock-and-roll moment we've all
experienced in our lives.
ED ROBERTSON: Alan Doyle
was standing backstage.
And after it happened,
he said, "That
is one of the top five
musical moments of my life.
And I wasn't even involved."
[LAUGHTER]
ADAM GREEN: That's amazing.
I can't think of a
better note to end on.
Thank you so much for
coming in to Google,
guys, for the conversation
and for the album.
ED ROBERTSON:
Thanks to the baby.
ADAM GREEN: The real
hero of the day.
[APPLAUSE]
ED ROBERTSON: Thank you baby.
If anyone would like
a photo with the baby,
just speak to his agent.
[LAUGHTER]
Her agent.
Her agent, sorry, baby.
ADAM GREEN: Thanks
for coming, you guys.
ED ROBERTSON: Thank
you, everybody.
TYLER STEWART: Thanks, guys.
ED ROBERTSON: Thank you.
Thank you, baby.
[APPLAUSE]